so let's now go to another interesting
interview that barack obama did over the
weekend barack obama was interviewed
with 60 minutes it was crazy
just like trump former president obama
walked out of the interview abruptly as
soon as he was asked the real question
i'm kidding obviously he didn't do that
unlike donald trump
who did do that a few weeks ago barack
obama sat there
and just answered the questions he was
asked we might not like every answer he
gave
but he just answered the questions
unlike donald trump who had to
abort the interview and walk out on
leslie stahl but i have some clips i do
want to look at with you
and what i found fascinating about this
interview is that barack obama obama's
talking about trump
as if he's a problem child who
misbehaves and he's sort of struggling
to deal
with a child it it reminded me of a
second grade teacher
explaining to the parents that listen
what what little donny is doing in class
it's not okay
but i need to talk to you about what's
going on at home to really have a chance
at fixing it
it felt like that type of a conversation
let's take a look at a little
a little bit of it and then discuss what
are these false claims
of widespread election fraud doing to
our country right now
the president doesn't like to lose and
never admits loss i'm more troubled by
the fact that other republican officials
who clearly know better
are going along with this are humoring
him in this fashion little donny doesn't
like to lose
or admit he lost but president obama
pointing out as i've been doing for some
time now that the problem
is not trump alone it's
republicans around trump and voters in
this case
because if every republican simply said
don
come on joe biden won joe biden's
president-elect
you've got to move on we would have a
very different scenario if right-wing
media did the same
this wouldn't now be dragging out into
what is almost week three at this point
in time
with 86 percent of trumpists believing
joe biden didn't legitimately win and
we'll talk about this
the idea here is the problem isn't
really trump the problem is the
republican party
you could have a trump if trump tried to
run as a democrat it would have gone
nowhere
trump ran as a republican and i'm not
going back to that debunked quote
that does that's not even a real quote
from trump from 20 years ago the reason
trump became president is because he ran
as a republican it wouldn't have worked
in the democratic party
and the problem is republicans to a
great degree and we will talk about that
but let's continue with this interview
um it is one more step in delegitimizing
not just the incoming biden
administration but democracy generally
and that's a dangerous path we would
never accept that out of
our own kids behaving that way if they
lost
right i i mean if if my daughter's
in any kind of competition uh
pouted and and then accused the other
side of uh
cheating when they lost when there was
no evidence of it we'd scold them
this is just perfect and i'd actually go
further it's not just
children that get scolded for acting the
way trump is acting
because trump is acting like a child
i've played
in sports leagues as an adult i've
played in soccer leagues i've played in
dodgeball we had a huge dodgeball
performance where the david pakman show
charity dodgeball team
won the tournament but imagine we had
lost and imagine that we started
saying the refs rigged it we actually
won
i mean even adults who behave this way
in any kind of competitive event would
be asked to leave
and that is what donald trump is doing
and then barack obama also pointed out
that there's been
huge normalization of insanity in the
last few years and he likens trump
to a strongman dictator you know i think
that there has been
this sense over the last several years
that
literally anything goes and is justified
in order to get power and
that's not unique to the united states
there are strong men and dictators
around the world who think
that i can do anything to stay in power
i can kill people i can throw them in
jail i can
run phony elections i can suppress
journalists
[Music]
but that's not who we're supposed to be
and
one of the signals i think that uh
joe biden needs to send to the world is
that no
those values that we preached and we
believed in and subscribed in we
still believe now literally as this
interview was wrapping up on 60 minutes
donald trump took to twitter and tweeted
this
humiliating screed quote why does the
fake news media continuously assume that
joe biden
will ascend to the presidency not even
allowing our side to show
which we are just getting ready to do
how badly
shattered and violated our great
constitution has been
in the 2020 election it was attacked
perhaps like never before
from large numbers of poll watchers that
were thrown out of vote counting rooms
in many of our states
to millions of ballots that have been
altered by democrats
only for democrats to voting after
the election was over to using radical
left owned dominion voting systems
turned down by texas and many others
because it was not good or secure
those responsible for the safeguarding
of our constitution cannot allow the
fake results of the 2020 mail-in
election to stand
the world is watching completely
humiliating i mean it's
it's we're going to go through the lies
in that in the next segment
but this is a humiliating
tragedy that the united states is going
through right now
we all we can do is put one foot in
front of the other
one day at a time and get to january
20th we really can't do anything else at
this point
let's talk about the twitter meltdown a
little bit here